Woohoo!
Meow!
Nya.
Are these my new owners?
Hello.
Nya.
Sorry.
My name is Doki.
Will you adopt me, please?
Nyao.
My owners abandoned me.
And I need a new home to live.
Will you please adopt me?
Nyao.
I am Doki.
I have three rules.
Rule number one.
You need to buy me lots of treats and toys, or I die.
Rule number two.
I get to have all the fishes in the world every day, or I die.
And rule number three.
Wait, what was my rule number three?
I don't...
I don't remember what I wrote on the paper.
Oh!
I need the softest beds.
The softest and biggest beds.
Or I die.
My sickness is very serious.
If you miss out on one day...
I die.
So will you adopt me, please?
Nyao.
Oh yeah, rule number...
Sorry, I add one more rule.
I'm a very demanding cat.
Rule number four.
If...
If you put me outside...
And make me touch grass...
I die.
So will you adopt me, please?
Nyao.
I am a dog kitty.
Look at my ears go.
Up, down.
Nyao.
Oh, you wanna see my fish?
Let me get my fish real quick.
Give me a sec.
Wait, let me show you my fish.
I grab the fish.
There's a lot of stuff in...
There's only... Actually, there's not a lot of stuff in this box.
There's like...
Like one thing in this box.
This is my fish.
Give me a sec.
You like my fish?
This is my personal fish.
But you gotta refill it.
Tomorrow or I die.
Alright, let me push my fish away.
Unless you're gonna refill my fish right now.
Let me put it away.
Yes!
I am your little...
Wait, not little.
Actually, this box is pretty big.
Not gonna lie.
I am your big kitty.
I am.
Dog kitty.
Anyway, so...
Happy April Fools, everybody!
Yes, Dogekitty is here.
Another addition to the Dogeverse.
I am Dogekitty.
It's different from Dogefield.
I am a lot different from Dogefield, as you see.
Because I...
I would say I'm less handsome than Dogefield.
But I still think people would like me.
But...
One of the best things...
One of the reasons why...
I appear to you today...
Is so I could do...
I can do this.
Greatest form.
I'm not a menace!
Did you not read the letters, dragons?
Did you not read the letter?
It says...
I am...
Wait, what did...
What's the letter say?
I don't remember.
I wrote it like...
I mean, not me.
I didn't write it.
My previous owners that abandoned me wrote it.
I'm not a stray cat.
I was...
I was not a stray street cat.
I swear to God.
I did not come up with this scam so I can be pampered at home.
And be a nice house...
And be a spoiled house cat.
I swear to...
I had previous owners.
I swear.
I swear I did.
That letter was written by my previous owner.
And I am not a stray cat.
Anyway...
So on that letter that my previous owner wrote...
And I didn't write because...
I'm not trying to scam my way into your nice lovely home, sir.
It's not that I saw that you had like...
Lots of...
Lots of food inside.
And you had like air conditioning and heat.
And you had like...
I saw all that lasagna and fish in there.
And the biggest bed...
Softest bed possible.
It's not that.
I had all of those before in my previous home.
Yes, yes, yes.
I had all of that over there too.
It's just that, you know...
My previous owners...
They had to...
They had to move, you know?
And so like...
They were like...
Oh my god.
These...
These new owners are gonna take real good care...
Of my...
Of my old kitty.
And...
Yeah.
No tixie-baxies.
Anyway...
Anyway, my letter.
In my letter...
It says...
She's...
A very good...
Not cause trouble.
That's me.
I not cause trouble.
I no cause trouble.
I'm a very good kitty.
After all, my name is Doe Kitty.
How could...
Would this face lie to you?
Look at that.
Look at this.
Come on!
Oh yes.
Because...
I can make all sorts of...
All sorts of faces.
Wait.
I don't remember...
I don't remember what kind.
But...
My tail...
My tail is back down.
Sorry.
What...
What can I do again?
I don't remember.
Oh.
No.
Wait.
You didn't see that.
You didn't see that, guys.
There's the doom.
The doom.
And then...
My little bearish...
Meow.
I'm a sleepy kitty.
I'm a really tired sleepy kitty.
And...
But I can be your smart cat too.
I can be your very, very smart cat.
Wow!
Or I can be your dead inside cat.
Please, I'm dying.
I didn't have my new toy today.
Please, Dragoon.
You read the rules.
You said...
You said you'd give me a new toy and a new treat every day.
And now I'm...
And now you're trying to skip today?
I'm dying now.
Quick, somebody give her a toy!
You want me to go outside?
Do you not...
Do you not want me?
And then, I can also...
I can also wear...
I found this on the street.
I mean, not the street.
If I go outside, I die.
That's why I was in the box, guys.
I never spend my life outside in the streets.
I've always been a house cat.
I know what it's like to be a house cat.
This was already...
This was already in my box.
It was in my old home.
Right there.
And then, I also have...
My fish.
My fish that was also in my box that I never went outside for.
And then...
And I can take off my jacket.
And...
That's just...
You didn't see that.
And then...
And I'm like...
Go baby, go outside, please.
Please.
I'll die.
And I'm like...
Oh my God.
Fish?
For me?
But then, also...
Wait.
But also, I also have...
I also have some...
Okay, wait.
I forgot to put this on.
Is that money?
Oh my God.
Super chat?
Shiny super chat.
Oh.
Wow.
Wait, I got something even better.
Oh my gosh, wait.
No!
I can't type words right now, because I...
Okay, no, I can.
Okay.
I can type words.
I forgot.
I have these by somewhere else.
Wait, wait, let me...
I got something even better though.
Okay, oh, this one.
I have something even better for you guys to show.
Alright, wait.
I found this in my box.
Give me a sec.
It was in my box.
Where's the picture?
Oh.
What?
What is that?
Why does it move around so much?
Oh my God!
Also...
That trip in that box was so much.
Ah!
Why didn't you put me down gently, Jackals?
And then...
Please don't make me go outside.
Please.
I'm allergic to grass.
I swear, I would not lie.
No, no.
I'll only take vet visits if it's in-house.
If I go outside, I die.
Please.
If I go outside, I'll die.
And then...
Also, I hope it's okay if I bring my friend along too.
My little buddy.
I have my own pet as well.
Here's dad.
It's a two-for-one!
You get a twofer!
Look at that!
That's my pet.
So, yes.
I also have my own pet.
Here's Jokey Amber Doge.
So, he lives with us too now.
So, we have a two-for-one deal as well.
So, yeah.
Anyway, thank you for...
Thank you for welcoming me to your home, Dragons.
I'm gonna love spending my days here.
Forever.
And ever.
Until you die.
Yes, that is my...
It is my pet-pet.
Just like in Neopets.
It's my pet-pet.
Alright.
Oh!
Oh, you have a room?
Oh, it's my room now?
Dragons?
You shouldn't have!
Really?
Oh my god.
Oh, thank you so much for giving me...
Giving me your room.
I really appreciate...
Oh!
You...
Oh my gosh.
Don't worry.
I already called people over in advance to decorate it to my liking while you were unpacking my box.
So don't worry.
They're already done with the box already.
So, you wanna check my room out now?
Come on!
Join me!
Wow!
Oh my god!
They worked really fast.
It's crazy that this used to be your room.
That's crazy.
Well, now it's my room.
How else am I gonna...
How else am I gonna like...
You want me to be bored?
You want me to die?
You read the rules.
You opened the package.
So, this is your fate now.
No, no, no.
It's my room now.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh yeah, we added like several floors.
If you live in like a house, we added several floors to your house.
So now it's a villa.
Now it's a little apartment building.
Welcome!
I basically raised your property value, dragons.
Can you really say no to me?
You really...
Can you really say no to this face?
Oh, with what money?
Don't worry.
I took several loans off of your name.
So, I hope you appreciate.
Don't worry, don't worry.
It's a good investment.
So, your credit's gonna be super fine, guys.
Your credit's gonna be okay.
But I took some loans under your name before my box got here.
Because I knew you would say yes anyway.
Your credit score is gonna be A-okay.
Trust me, guys.
Trust me.
But yes.
I love my new room.
Thank you so much, dragons.
I really love my new room that you've given me.
It's really nice.
I love how they decorated it and everything, too.
Oh my gosh.
But yes.
Oh my gosh, I love how my ears...
My ears...
Go up.
Down.
Up.
And then I can do...
I also have four ears, so I can hear better.
So I can hear you better.
So, don't try anything funny.
Don't try anything silly.
Oh yes, oh yes.
Since we're here, I believe...
I believe you guys want one thing and it's photo time.
Is it photo time or do I...
Or for April Fools, I just...
The greatest joke of all time.
There's no photo shoot.
Do I do that to you guys?
Do I actually...
That is the greatest joke...
That is the greatest prank of all time.
No photo shoot for...
For Dogekitty.
Please, please, please.
No photos.
Not for...
No photos, please.
Please, respect my privacy.
Respect Dogekitty's privacy.
The paparazzi, please.
Stop, no.
Stop following me.
Please, if you wish to...
If you wish to access the photos...
Please visit my own...
OnlyCat's website.
OnlyCat slash Dogekitty.
To receive exclusive cat photos.
For...
Cause it's not for free.
Not the OnlyCat.
No!
Yes.
Okay, so...
All I'm gonna say...
Is that, by the way...
I...
I hate the CRA.
But now that I'm doing...
But like, how could I hate the CRA...
If I'm a cat?
I'm a...
I don't have to...
Cats don't have to worry about taxes.
Cats don't have to worry about paying rent.
I just chose a home and now I live here.
Now I live here and you pay the taxes.
And I can just live.
Cats don't have to worry about real life adult issues.
Cats can just go...
And then I get everything I want.
Alright,
alright, alright.
How much do you...
How badly do you want to photoshoot dragons?
How badly do you want it?
Is this what you guys are right now?
No photos.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Maybe...
Maybe one photo.
Okay, done.
April Fools!
Okay,
okay, okay.
I'll give you guys a photoshoot.
Whoa.
Yeah?
I actually put my tail down because, you know, it's part of my body.
Uh, let me see.
Well, now the tail is down.
But it doesn't have to be.
And then I can... my tail can go super fast.
Like, wow!
I get the zoomies.
Oh my...
And then I'll be like...
Huh?
Oh my God.
Whoa!
I get the little zoomies.
I also put my tail down.
But you guys can't really see where it...
My tail is like down there.
But I'll put it up here for better photos.
And then I can...
Keep on that toggle.
That entices me a little bit more.
My dignity is on the line.
Can you...
Can you buy my dignity?
We'll see there.
Alright, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh shit!
Oh, that's a...
That's like a freebie.
Okay, there.
Yeah.
Do the zero point...
Yeah, do the 0.00 speed there.
Alright, what else?
Oh, there's like...
And then...
I'm so tired.
Tired kitty.
I love buying your dignity.
Okay.
Okay, I'll do it later.
I'll do it later.
But I'm also a smart kitty too.
I'm a smart kitty.
Yeah.
I'm business cat.
Who let this cat in my office?
And then I go like...
I like clicking and smack things down.
I smack things down like the desk and stuff.
But I can be a dead inside kitty.
Oh, dead inside kitty.
And...
Very dead inside kitty.
Another day, another dollar.
Another...
And then I also have...
I have my glasses that was always inside my box and I didn't find on the street because I'm not a straight kitty.
I'm a good kitty.
And then I also have...
My fish.
My little fish buddy.
Oh wait, I can do...
You know, that cat may may.
And I also can take off my jacket.
And then...
Oh, no, we don't want that.
I don't want to be a...
It's all just guy build.
And then...
Sad.
Very sad.
Meow.
Wow, is that fish?
Fish!
And then...
Big fish!
Shiny?
And then...
Dizzy.
I'm so dizzy.
And then...
The grass touched me.
Oh my god.
A piece of grass touched me.
I need a doctor.
Someone, please.
Get the vet.
Oh, and then there's...
There's dad, but he's cut up a little bit.
So, like...
I could fix this, but I'm a little...
Okay, I could fix...
I should fix this.
I was like...
I could fix this, or I don't.
I fixed it.
Look, see?
He's okay now.
Yeah!
And then...
Wait, okay.
Alright.
Finally.
You freaks all wanted...
I think it was like this.
Oh, wait, no.
It's this.
This.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Off it goes.
Off it...
Okay, wait, wait.
Alright.
Alright, there we go.
That's good enough.
That should be...
That should be good enough.
Guys, stop!
Stop!
No cameras!
Please!
It was the last one!
Judgment!
I got into the catnip!
Okay?
Please!
No cameras!
Don't get me got into some catnip!
It violated the terms of services!
Get out!
The fish?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Alright.
Fish.
I love fish.
Oh my god, I fucking love fish.
Oh my god.
This fish is so fucking good.
Man, I love...
I fucking love fish.
Let me get fish a little.
Bro, I just really, really love fish.
What can I say?
Alright,
photoshoot.
Photoshoot's over, guys.
Back to my room.
But yes!
Did you guys like my little April Fools?
This is real, though.
This is canon.
It's like, April Fools is over.
I snap and Doughkitty's gone forever.
This is the last time you've ever seen Doughkitty.
She's just gone forever.
Don't worry, Doughkitty's forever.
So, I'll still be here, guys!
You saw the letter, right?
I mean, like, I'll still be here.
Like, you guys agreed to the letter.
And I already put your...
Used your credit to get several loans to make this place.
So, you know.
I don't wanna waste the money.
Don't you remember?
The contract you agreed to?
To adopting Doughkitty?
Don't worry.
I didn't write this, by the way.
I definitely didn't write this.
I am not a stray cat that scammed my way into your home.
I would never.
I have always been a nice, pampered, spoiled house kitty.
But anyway, this is what my previous owner wrote to you.
Which you agreed and signed.
Sign it.
Don't worry.
No, you know the bottom, right?
That little paw print?
That's your signature right there.
Okay, so I'll read it for you guys.
That you legally agreed to.
Hello, dragons.
Please, take care of this kitty.
That's me.
I'm the kitty.
That's...
That's me.
She is very good.
Not cause trouble.
That's me.
Please feed lots of fish.
Or she die.
That's also me.
Can only sleep in softest bed.
Or she die.
Please buy her treats and toys.
Every day.
Or she die.
It's a very sad disease.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's...
There's no cure for it.
So like, if you miss out...
I forgot...
There's an addendum in there.
There's an additional rule in there.
Is that please don't let outside.
Or she die.
My owner forgot to write that rule down.
But don't worry.
You're lucky I'm a talking cat.
So I'm just like Meowth.
Meow.
And like, I can tell you that...
If you let me outside.
Or if grass touches me.
I also die.
So don't worry.
Don't worry.
I help you avoid like...
Expensive medical vet bills.
By telling you that.
Anyway.
But yes.
It's a very serious.
Very serious.
Very...
There's no cure for this disease that I have.
But like, other than that.
You just follow...
Follow all of these very easy simple rules.
And then...
You have yourself a cat.
JL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey Doge Kitty.
Can I get a belated birth meow wish?
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear JL.
Yay.
Happy birthday.
Wow.
It's happy...
Happy April 1st.
I mean...
April 1st.
I...
Doge Kitty came into being.
That's me.
I'm Doge Kitty.
I came into being as a mere thought.
A month ago.
And now I'm here.
Not even a month ago.
I think like two...
Two and a half weeks ago.
And now...
And then I was born.
And now I'm part of the Dogeverse.
Pikachu.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Can we please...
Okay.
I'll give you the long neck again.
I think it was this.
No, it wasn't.
It was this.
Wait.
No, it wasn't.
It was this.
There we go.
This is...
I fight like giraffes.
You know like how giraffes...
Giraffes, they like bash each other.
I'm a long cat.
Long cat.
Wow.
You know how like when you pick up a cat and they're longer than they are?
This is what happens when you pick me up.
My neck just...
My neck expands when you pick me up.
Now you know...
Now you guys know why I didn't start the stream right away.
Because I knew that like you guys...
Wouldn't want to miss it out.
Don't say I never give you a...
It was like...
Doki, we're so starving.
Where's the fan service, Doki?
I'm gonna die, please.
I'm so thirsty.
Don't say I never give you nothing.
With a little bit of debt, here you go.
Anyway, but that's why, that's why.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I mean, there's not really much difference with the full bot.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me go back to the green screen.
I gotta...
Disappear!
Where did the cat go?
Where did I go?
Okay, I need to...
Alright.
There's really nothing much different with...
I reappear!
There's really not much different with...
Okay, but I can put my tail down like this.
Which is what you don't see.
So I have my tail down like that.
But I can...
My tail can go super fast.
And then...
But then I can make it go up.
When I get super excited.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm like super excited right now.
And then...
Like I said, there's not really much different.
I mean, I just have cat ears and a tail.
So...
And there's my tail.
Yeah, now I can go up.
Down.
Up.
Yeah, and then when I look this way.
And then...
I can make my tail go like that.
And like that.
Like that.
And then, I guess if you want...
Angry kitty.
Meow.
Wait, let me cough up a hairball.
Now you know why I lose at all of this.
Don't get it.
No.
That's right.
On your couch too.
On your couch.
Not on my couch.
Oh yeah, here.
There's...
Aviator kitty.
No kitty.
Right there.
Someone get the...
Get the spray bottle.
Wait, wait, let me...
Where's the...
Wait, what's this?
Oh, this was dead inside.
Okay, wait.
You want the spray bottle?
Wait, I got you.
I got you.
What is this?
What?
Oh, there's dad.
Wait, there's gonna be like several emotions coming out.
Because I'm trying to type right now.
Okay.
What was Y again?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
And then...
Whoa!
I don't remember what all of my things are.
I don't rem...
Oh, there it is.
I fixed it.
Alright.
Let me grab it for you guys.
Real quick.
Alright.
It's not very intuitive how I did this.
It's definitely not very intuitive.
Not very smart of me.
Okay, we're...
Spray bottle.
Spraying.
Just for the photoshoot.
I'll do it for the photoshoot.
Alright.
Dive down.
No!
I gotta pay for this?
No way.
I'm not paying for shit.
I'm not paying for this.
It's a spray bottle.
It's a goddamn spray bottle.
Where the heck is the transparent...
Oh, there it is.
Wait.
Can I download this one?
Sorry, guys.
I'm trying to find a free...
A free spray bottle for us, guys.
It's a little...
Who would've thought?
This is very difficult to find.
Is there no transparent spray bottle?
I gotta...
I gotta pay to use a transparent spray bottle?
What the fuck?
Okay, I'll just use this.
This is free, right?
Guys, it wasn't free.
How could this be possible?
Oh, I found a free.
Don't worry.
I got it.
You wouldn't download a car, would you?
Okay, I'm gonna use this, guys.
But there is...
There is a watermark on...
Oh, no!
I can't!
They made it so I...
Oh, I can.
Okay.
I got this, guys.
Don't worry.
It does have a watermark, though.
Ah!
No!
Oh, my God.
It's spraying watermarks on me!
No!
I won't be able to own my own image!
Okay.
That's the...
That's the spray bottle.
Your rights are that...
No!
You might be noticing something's missing on my head.
But that's cause I'm Doki.
I'm not Doki Bird.
I'm Doki.
Hello?
Ooh.
Yeah.
Yes.
Alright, photoshoot over again.
True.
We need the shock Doki reaction meme.
Wait, what is it?
Yeah, I don't have my feather.
Because I never had a feather.
What do you mean?
I'm Doki.
I'm...
Empty eyes.
What?
Alright, I'll give you that.
But you don't get the green screen.
That's right.
April fools.
Okay, I think...
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's...
Oh, my gosh.
I keep getting confused which one is which.
Okay, it's this.
And...
It's this and this.
April fools, no green screen for you.
Yeah.
It's a nice little...
Nice little...
April fools day for all of you guys.
I figured I wanted to do something more fun with you guys.
Something...
Something I can also use more in the future.
If she evolves, she'll be Doki.
Oh, for those who missed out.
For those who missed out.
I want to say a huge thank you to several people who helped me out with all of this.
So, as always, the 3D animation was done by Ramen.
The box was 3D modeled by SaltedFish.
The box was drawn...
First drawn digitally by Shio.
Sorry, I didn't have all the credits written.
But I will thank them in that post tweet.
So...
And...
What else?
Celia, rigging everything.
Helping making me my new skin suit move.
Making Doki.
And then my mama, Kamame.
For drawing the...
For designing the cat ears and the cat tail.
Huge shout out to all of them.
Always love working with all these people.
To make all of this happen.
And Hibi for helping me write my note.
See, I told you, I didn't write the note.
For those who missed out on the animation, let me show you guys the animation again.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
That is such a cute animation.
Also, I think, honestly, this is definitely my favorite.
This is like, one of the main reasons why I wanted to do this.
This is honestly one of the main reasons why.
Okay, I don't know, I just fucking love this meme.
The spiritual successor to the last time I did this meme.
But now, now I'm Doki.
Now it makes more sense.
As Doki.
It's just...
I tried to find a salad.
But like, I couldn't find...
They put too much salad in my salad.
So like, pasta works too.
Anyway, back to my desk.
My...
My room that you graciously gave me.
But...
I'm not gonna lie.
I hope you guys enjoyed...
My little...
My little April Fools for all of you guys.
It was a very, you know...
Truly...
Very, very, very short surprise.
Didn't really have too much planned for it.
But I still hope you guys enjoyed this little April Fools.
Yeah.
But I still wanna spend...
I still wanna spend...
Time with all of you guys.
Right now.
So I'll read through some Super Chats for now.
Oh yeah.
Also, I'll give you a life update.
Before I start reading Super Chats.
I went to bed at 7 in the morning.
Today.
Because I had to stay up.
And call the CRA.
For those who don't know...
What the CRA...
Thank God I'm a cat right now.
Thank God.
Doki is taking a break from taxes.
Doki needs a break from fucking taxes and the CRA.
For those who don't know what the CRA is.
The CRA is basically the IRS.
But for Canadians.
So it's our tax system.
And so I tried to call them.
Earlier.
People and members know why I have to call them.
So if you guys wanna know the full story of why I need to call the CRA.
You should join the members.
Anyway.
That's right.
Nice segue, right?
Anyway.
So I tried to call them yesterday.
But their offices closed at 8 for me.
And so...
Their offices closes at 8.
So I was on hold for 2 hours.
By the way.
I was on hold for 2 hours.
At the CRA.
Hotline.
And then like...
And then at the moment.
The moment it strike 8.
They were like.
Offices are now closed now.
Call again next time.
Bye.
I was like.
What?
What do you mean?
And my fish.
Angrily eats my fish.
Yum...
So.
And then.
I googled it.
I was like.
Okay.
So.
What time do I call then?
And then so, everybody was like.
You should call at 5 in the morning.
Or when it opens.
But I didn't realize.
By the way.
I fucked up because I didn't realise.
They actually.
Like the old post.
Before then, they open at 5 in the morning for PST, but they recently made it so that calls open at 3.30 in the morning.
So I should have googled the CRA hours because I was reading like a Reddit post that said 5 in the morning because that was a year ago.
But this year, apparently, they start running at 3.30 AM.
But silly me, I waited at 5 in the morning to make my call and I was still put on hold for 40 minutes.
I waited at 5 in the morning to call.
I called exactly at 5 and I was put on hold for 40 minutes.
And then, and then they're like, we can't help you.
You have to send a letter to your tax center.
You have to send a phys- and I was like, a physical letter?
And they're like, yes, a physical letter, not by email.
You have to write a physical letter to your tax center and then wait 15 days.
Process your request and then you have to call back to this hotline and do the thing you want to do.
And then I was like...
Okay, thank you so much for the help.
I was on hold for almost three hours just to be told to write a physical letter.
So that was my day and now I'm a cat.
Cats don't need to call the CRA.
Cats don't need to pay rent.
Cats don't need to pay a corporate income tax and file tax returns.
And now I'm a cat.
Become cat to avoid taxes.
Anyway, so that happened to me today.
Cafe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My dearest tax representative, I'm sorry I could not submit my tax on time.
I was a silly cat.
I have to wait 15 days anyway.
I can just write the letter tomorrow.
I'll write the letter tomorrow.
Today I just want to be a cat.
It takes 15 days anyway.
Does it really matter?
I'm a kitty.
If I pay taxes, I die.
Thank you for the super chat.
Interesting man.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
Why are you just a selfie?
Anyway, that was my cat day.
My non-cat day.
And now I'm a cat and I'm a little happier now.
Yay.
Reject humanity.
Zero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you to CRA for mentally bringing my Oshi into giving up and becoming a cat girl.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And also, after calling the CRA, I had to call my bank because I had to file my corporate taxes and stuff.
So like, I was like, how do you do this?
And then I was on hold for an hour plus for that too, right after.
Right after I couldn't get a hold of the CRA, I had to call my bank.
And then they were like, they were like, I was on hold for an hour because I was like, why can't I log in via your partner bank?
So for those who don't know, this is how the CRA works.
You can log into your CRA account, your tax account via your partner banks.
So like, I was like, why can't I log in via my partner bank?
That's part of my business.
And then I called them.
I was so confused because I want to pay my fucking company taxes.
And then when I got hold of them, she was like, oh, sorry, we don't use that anymore.
It got removed in 2024 in October.
So we don't use the, we don't, we're not like partnered with the CRA anymore.
With the, you have to use like our own personal, our own personal online banking to like log in to do your taxes.
And I was like, what?
And I was like, okay, where do I go?
And she was like, oh, sorry, like I'm not a financial expert regarding like taxes.
So like, but you could go to this tab where it says like, um, there's a tax tab under pay bills.
And then you go through the steps.
And then there was like 70 options regarding what taxes you want to pay.
And I was like, which one do I press?
I want to, which one is it?
I need to pay my company taxes.
And she was like, sorry, I can't help you with that.
You should ask your accountant.
And I was like, my accountant doesn't really know what the fuck, like my accountant doesn't use this particular bank.
That's why I called you.
And then she was like, maybe just ask your accountant.
And I was like, okay.
Luckily, um, I like had a three, two hour email back and forth with my accountant.
And then she, I had to like show screenshots of the, like, I was like, what do I pick?
And she had to look through all 70 options.
And was like, pick this one.
That should be the company taxes you're supposed to pay.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
I was like, are you sure?
And it was like, it was like every step I had to do.
I had to take a picture of like what it, like take a snapshot of like each tab, like each thing I have to fill out.
And then like the accountant like emails me back of like what I did put for each of them.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
Anyway, I still need to fix my CRA account though.
So, gotta write a letter, an actual physical letter.
And then wait 15 days to process.
And then call the bank after, not bank, call CRA again after I received the thing I requested.
So, I'm a cat now.
So,
that was my day.
I can all, I can just be a silly cat.
And that's why I'm here now, guys.
That's why.
Anyway, thank you everybody for the super chats.
I really do appreciate it, guys.
Thank you everybody so much for all the support, guys.
Of me being a silly cat to avoid the scary real world out there.
To avoid the scary real world.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to go back out there, guys.
I don't want to go back.
Anyway, let me see.
I don't want to read them out.
Blake, thank you for the magenta, super.
Thank you, thank you.
We need, she said, what face, kitty?
Wait, what is that face?
I don't know that face.
She said, what face, cat?
She said, what?
That's like the only thing I could think of when I hear that.
What is that, like...
Reject humanity, become cat.
Ania, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's a half face.
Cats, before you go, can you say meowty, dragons?
Meowty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nexy, thank you again for the aqua super and for buying my dignity.
How much dignity do I have left?
Thank you for the aqua super.
Thank you, thank you.
JL, thank you for the aqua super.
I got my digital camera ready.
Thank you for the aqua super.
Thank you, thank you.
JL, thank you again.
Oh, no, don't, kitty.
My heart.
Wait, I hear my wallet making a run for it.
Thank you for the aqua super.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Alright, guys.
I'm gonna be...
This was an incredibly short stream, but don't worry, everybody.
Oh my god, I can't believe an hour passes by already.
That's crazy.
That's actually really crazy.
An hour passed by so fast.
But...
You won't say no to Don't Kitty, right?
But tonight, I'll be streaming some Rivals to get my quota up.
I'll be getting my quota hours on Twitch very soon.
Not soon, sorry.
Not very soon.
I haven't eaten dinner, by the way.
All I had was my fish.
All I had was my...
Anyway, I haven't had...
I haven't had dinner yet, so I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna get dinner.
And then, I'll update you guys in maybe two to three hours.
In two to three hours...
When I'll be ready to go back into the mines.
Go back to the Rival mines to farm away those hours.
Thank you again, everyone.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday with lots of meows.
Thank you for the cute stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Rodrigo, thank you, thank you.
Of course, happy birthday to meow.
Happy birthday to meow.
Happy birthday, dear Rodrigo.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday, everybody!
People legally changing their name to Rodrigo now.
It should've been me!
Oh, my God.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys later.
Dough Kitty is gonna go get some dough food.
Happy April Fools, everybody.
Of course, this is not the last you'll see Dough Kitty.
Don't worry.
I'll be back.
Maybe tonight.
I'll just be a cat for tonight.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you all for coming.
Happy April Fools, everyone.
I hope you guys like your little...
Your little April Fools stream.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get your blood flowing.
And instead of...
Head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Whoa.
Secret ending, but also, oh my God, I'm everywhere.
Do not be afraid.